Die Bedeutung des Quantencomputings wird gleichzeitig unterschätzt
und maßlos übertrieben.
Obwohl es herkömmliche Computer nicht ersetzen wird,
stellt die Quanteninnovation ein völlig neues Rechenparadigma dar.
Quantencomputer können Hand in Hand mit bestehender Recheninfrastruktur
arbeiten, um komplexe Probleme zu lösen, die bisher
als unpraktisch oder unmöglich galten.
Das kann ein Paradigmenwechsel sein.
So ist zum Beispiel die Schwierigkeit, große Zahlen
in ihre Primfaktoren zu zerlegen, die Grundlage moderner
Kryptographie. Bei Zahlengrößen, wie sie in modernen
Public-Key-Verschlüsselungsverfahren verwendet werden, würde diese Berechnung
den schnellsten herkömmlichen Computer über 300 Billionen Jahre in Anspruch nehmen.
Für einen großskaligen Quantencomputer, der mit
Shors Algorithmus arbeitet, könnte diese Berechnung Sekunden dauern.
Solche komplexen Probleme gibt es in allen Branchen.
Die möglichen Anwendungsgebiete des Quantencomputings
sind gewaltig.
Quantencomputer werden bereits immer größer
und leistungsfähiger,
da wir uns an immer komplexere Probleme heranwagen.
Seit 2016 hat IBM Quantencomputer der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht –
über eine Website mit einer grafischen Benutzeroberfläche, die
wie eine Notenpartitur aussieht,
sowie das Software-Development-Kit Qiskit,
mit dem Nutzer Quantencomputer programmieren können.
Wissenschaftler innerhalb und außerhalb der Unternehmenswelt
führen Experimente durch
über ähnliche Portale. Sie erkunden Ansätze für Chemie-
und maschinelle Lernprobleme und versuchen herauszufinden,
welche Fragen sie stellen können
und wie sie diese Fragen formulieren werden,
sobald die Technologie weiter ausgereift ist. Jetzt ist der
richtige Zeitpunkt für Unternehmensführer, sich auf
Quantum vorzubereiten. Die Voraussetzungen sind da, um mit dieser
grundlegend neuen Technologie zu experimentieren und sie auszubauen.
Organisationen, die an der Spitze dieses
transformativen Wandels stehen wollen, werden
sich Wettbewerbsvorteile sichern. Dieses Training
bereitet dich darauf vor, deine Quantenreise zu beginnen!